Sharyn Abbott, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you today?
Wonderful. Thank you.
Sharyn, you had a dream
in the year about 2000, right?
To create something big,
to create something
really magical and impactful.
What was that dream?
I had been talking to my brother
at Christmas in December of 2000,
and we were talking about the fact that
he was adopted by my parents
and how many children in the US.
There's 200,000 children
who are living on the streets
without a parent or an adult
to help guide them or protect them.
200,000?
200,000 under 18 years old
with not a single adult
to take care of them.
And it broke my heart.
And so my brother Tony and I,
decided that we would do something
which is create a school for kids at risk,
to help get kids off the streets
from the United States.
And so, we were going to do
a little school, 350 kids.
350 boys.
Because at 15 years old,
there's no programs out there
for these kids.
There's programs for six year olds,
there's programs for 10 year olds.
People will take in a 10 year old,
but not a 15 year old.
So, we decided we would do something
to help get these kids.
They really need a break,
they really need somebody
to champion them.
And so, I started the process of,
let's create something.
And so, that became
Ultimate Business University, UBU.
And it's just a great acronym for
I want kids to learn
how to be themselves.
And then my brother passed away in 2008.
And before he passed away, I promised him
that I would make this school happen.
And because I had so much time,
I sold my house, my car,
my jewelry, everything,
and I went all in on an investment.
I have no home, I have no car,
I have nothing.
And what I have
is in a five by ten storage unit
and I am 100% invested
in making the school happen for kids.
And I am days away.
It could be tomorrow,
it could be Friday,
but I am days away
from having the investment mature
so that I can not only start a school
for 6,000 boys and girls
from the United States.
They will be moved to Belize
so a judge will interview them
and the judge will say,
you can go to juvenile hall
because you stole food
because you're hungry;
or you broke into a building
because you need to get out of the cold,
or you need to get out of the heat;
or you can go to police
and have a three year high school program.
And in 15 years old,
kids can be emancipated
and they can choose
what they want to do with their life.
So, we now will have
in a three year time period,
taking 500 boys, 500 girls
every six months,
move them to Belize;
and we have five judges
across the country;
and they will be able to have
the most progressive education
that will have trade school,
will have the required curriculum,
we will have auto mechanics,
we will have agriculture, horticulture,
we will have animal husbandry,
we'll have every practical skill there is
so that these kids will always know
that they can fend for themselves.
And we will do things
to bring them out of,
imagine living on the street
and having to survive.
And the differences
the kids have to develop
to survive, right?
So, we will help break down those defenses
so they get a chance to live their life
without having anger, abandonment issues,
all the things that come from
having to live on the streets
and be completely responsible
for your own life.
One boy I met was 12 years old.
He comes home from school,
his mother moved
and didn't even tell him
where she was going.
So, he has been on his own on the street
since he was 12 years old.
He's now 28,
remarkable young man,
he goes around the world
and he teaches people how to make farm
so that they can be self-sustaining,
creating food for themselves.
Imagine a young man doing that
because he was homeless
and he feels so much for people
who can't take care of themselves.
So, that's the dream.
And we are within days,
I have 165 people on my team
from 38 countries.
We have everything
from the agriculture, horticulture.
We have people,
my farm director is from Dublin, Ireland.
I have, my landscape architect
is from Turkey.
I have a shipping director
who is from Mombasa.
I mean, it is so incredible.
I have people like my COO, Tom,
built the Civic Center in Las Vegas,
nine billion dollar project.
And he wants to walk away
from this corporate construction world
and come and help
bring this project to life.
I have spent four years
trying to connect with people
who are in Shanghai
who have a company called Winsome.
And four months ago, my guy from India,
who is also part of the farming,
he connected with the branch in Nigeria,
and two days ago,
I got the final agreement
that we're going to partner
that we will be able to use 3D printing
to build the school.
400,000 square feet,
six storey buildings in one week,
inhabitable in four weeks.
We can build 10, 15,
100 square foot homes a day,
inhabitable in four weeks.
So, we are taking
the idea of construction.
We will have the first 3D printed town
where there will be 27,000 residents
after we have the three year high school,
the four year university
and all the people
that it takes to survive.
Our own town
where we will create this,
I call it Neotopia, the new utopia,
the way people want to live.
So, you don't have to lock your door;
you trust the people
that you live next to;
that you can walk around.
It's a town so you can walk around
and feel perfectly safe,
your kids are safe.
You don't have to worry
about somebody taking advantage of you.
This is the way the world should be.
This is our own Neotopia,
the way we want the world to be.
And it starts in Belize
and then we will expand to 24 countries
within 12 to 15 years.
So, it's a big big project.
Sharyn, a lot of people
talk about their dreams
and about their aspirations and goals.
You're starting off with Christmas,
I guess, 20 years ago, with a dream.
I'm very sorry to hear
that your brother passed away.
But I can only imagine the impact
that you're having
and you're going to have
on so many thousands of lives.
Not just the impact, by the way,
that it will happen
when the project comes to fruition,
they're actually there.
But I was tearing up here,
listening to the story
of how you founded this
and how this is going to touch
so many thousands of youth.
And I think about
a lot of youth that I see.
We're talking here about kids
who really have very little,
very unfortunate upbringing
in their surroundings.
Yeah, they have nothing.
And what amazes me is,
we think about the United States,
you know the United States
has only three countries
that are worse than we are here in the US
for kids dying of malnutrition
before they're two years old?
I mean, this is inexcusable.
I mean, we have one in five adults
goes to bed hungry every single day
in this country.
And I just did the math
a couple of weeks ago
because somebody made this comment
that the United States is so big,
that the whole world population
could fit into the United States.
If every person in the world,
eight and a half billion people
lived in the United States,
every single person
would have a quarter of an acre.
And yet, what?
People are homeless,
people have no food,
people have no education,
they have no power,
they have no running water,
what is the excuse for that?
So, we will have 28 divisions
that address those issues
all over the world.
So, one of our first projects
as we're building the school
is called Little Syria.
And we will take a million people
who are in Syrian refugee camps
and move them to a brand new land,
3D print their entire country.
So, four buildings
that are 400,000 square feet,
that's the infrastructure.
We can house a million people
in just two months.
Then we end up building their homes,
with 10 printers
we can build a hundred homes a day.
We will teach them to be self-sustaining,
they will never have to worry
about another country or other people
coming in to try to take over.
They will be completely taken care of,
but taught to take care of themselves.
And why hasn't this happened before?
The oldest refugee camp is in India, 1983.
The oldest refugee camp.
The UN has the resources.
Why does that still exist?
And I'm not even going to tell you
the travesties that go on there.
Because it is heartbreaking,
it is disgusting,
it is not human to treat people this way.
So, when we look at
how the world has changed
and thank goodness at your age,
you're not aware of some of the things
that have happened in the world.
But we're in an age
where there are a lot of us
who are now going to step up and make sure
that these things never happen again.
So, within five years, no hunger.
Did you know that 100,000,000 a year
eliminates hunger around the world?
Not one person would ever go to bed hungry
with $100,000,000 a year.
Did you know that the Nobel Peace Prizes,
the awards are paid for
through the platform
that was started after World War Two?
If somebody put 100,000,000
on a platform
and dedicated that to world hunger,
there could be no hunger anywhere.
So, we will do that.
Since nobody else is bothered,
we will do that.
So, how many things can be addressed
by somebody just being aware of it?
Why are people homeless?
Why is it in California
where you are, where I am?
There are no institutions
since Reagan was governor
to take care of people
who have mental disorders.
That's where a lot of our homeless
come from, because there's no places
for them to live.
So, what if we create
an environment, a camp
for these people to go
to feel like they're outside,
to feel like they have the freedom.
But they have to do things
to be self-sustaining.
But to create an environment
where they don't feel threatened,
and if you go north, to Oakland,
now, I made myself do this
because I see a problem
and I put myself
in the center of the problem
because were I'm in the middle of it,
I get really creative.
So, I'm walking around Oakland
a year ago, November,
and I have to walk around
three feet of trash everywhere,
all along Broadway
which is a beautiful area.
When Jerry Brown was governor
and when he was mayor of San Francisco,
he made these areas really beautiful.
He took them out of this impoverished area
and he made them absolutely gorgeous.
Well, they're just trash now.
Weeds up to your waist, trash everywhere,
homeless people.
I walked up Broadway
and had a homeless guy bump into me
and he yelled at me
because he hit me from his right side
and he's blind in his right eye.
Like I'm supposed to know this?
And it's like, why isn't somebody
taking care of this man.
Why is he living homeless on the streets?
And why does he feel
like he has to be so defenseless?
It's inhumane how we treat people.
We treat animals better
than we treat a lot of human beings.
We look at veterans.
The idea of somebody going off,
you've been there,
you go serve the military
and you come home and you have nothing.
But maybe you have shell shock,
maybe you have PTSD.
And there is a young man
who played for the Oakland Raiders
and I worked with him 15 years ago,
and he has PTSD and he can't hold the job.
But he also played
for the Oakland Raiders.
So, there's a dichotomy there
that doesn't make sense.
Like why hasn't somebody said,
"Okay, you don't have to be on the edge
all the time and scratching every day
for your survival."
"What else could you do?"
So, I came up with a program
where I'd said,
"Why don't you go out
and interview all the people
you played football with,
create an audio program,
and then go out and speak
in front of high school students
and then be able to sell this."
These are the famous
famous football players.
He didn't have the wherewithal to do that.
So, I said,
"I'll do the interviews."
He didn't have the wherewithal
to be able to give me their names.
And he is a well known ex football player.
People are left at the wayside.
There's one person who played
from the Oakland A's,
at the same time,
another person did Vida Blue,
and makes $10,000
every time he speaks publicly.
The other person he worked with, Mike,
who was on the Oakland A's
at the same time, he's on disability.
He had eight back surgeries
because of baseball.
He has nothing.
Why is there such a disparity
in the way they live their lives?
Sharyn, I have to say that
from what we're talking about here,
first of all, I completely agree,
these are awful issues.
And I'm very inspired by the way
that you're approaching them.
And you're not just saying
there are issues,
but you're also putting yourself
in the center of them
and thinking creatively
how to address them.
One of the things
that I'm taking for myself
as an entrepreneur and on my journey,
talking about back to the school
that you're creating
and talking about the Syrian refugees,
a million refugees
and building a sustainable community
for them to live
in a matter of weeks or months,
it's unbelievable.
And a lot of it is because of technology
and because of innovation,
this idea that you can 3D print
a community or a school.
I mean, that's exactly why I came
to the Bay Area after my service.
And that is exactly
why I started this show,
it's to gain perspective
on what are the different ways
that us technologists
can leverage deep technology
and interesting technology
to impact the lives of people
for the better.
And a lot of people can say
one way to do that is through
better digital transformations
on our own computers screens.
Another way could be
to actually go and build cities
and build schools and share.
What you're talking about here
is literally saving lives.
And I'm getting so much
inspiration from these stories.
Sharyn, obviously the things
that you're doing now are incredible,
they're completely inspiring.
You have an incredible background
of working with tech companies and tech.
You've mentioned that
you've also lectured at Stanford
quite a few times.
You were on Oprah Winfrey
talking about your projects.
So, talk to me a little bit about
where you came from,
what excited you throughout your career.
We don't have much time left,
but I'd love to hear a little bit about
who Sharyn Abbot is.
So, I grew up in a very small town.
There were 10,000 people
in 10 square miles.
And we grew the food that we ate
and we traded for what we didn't grow.
And you never locked the door.
Everybody knew who you were.
Everybody watched out for each other.
And to me, that's the way
the world should be.
It was hard for me to adjust
to being in a world that wasn't like that.
And so I'm looking to bring my world,
my sphere of influence back to that.
Where people are happy every day
doing what they love to do
and not doing the job
just because they have to survive.
Where I grew up,
one person in the family worked
and everybody was able to survive
and do well.
Today, two people in the family
have to work
and the children never see their parents.
So, in the United States,
children under 12 years old,
65% never see their parents
other than on the weekends.
To me, that's wrong.
We should not put people in that position.
So, how do I take
the things that I loved about growing up
in the middle of Mendocino,
in the town of Mendocino,
three and a half miles inland
with 80 acres of state forests
surrounding me, to the point where
we were free, we had fun,
we knew what fun was, basic fun.
And today, kids don't know so much
about that because they're glued
to a computer screen.
They're playing games all the time.
I look around and I think,
what are people missing out on.
What inspired me, I was very fortunate,
I had dyslexia, I stuttered,
I had teachers
that pulled me aside and said,
"If you do this,
then this will be the result."
My sophomore year in high school, I said,
"I need to go to college."
And each one of my teachers said,
"Here's your assignment."
And I graduated with a 3.8,
when my sophomore year
I started out with a 2.0.
The teachers made the difference.
And because I have always seemed
to attract people to come into my life,
to inspire me, to help me, to guide me,
I've had amazing mentors in my life,
I have people that have opened up doors,
I have managed to be on a sales team
for a Fortune 500 company,
I've had my own companies,
I taught entrepreneurial skills
for 20 years only because
the Chamber of Commerce in Walnut Creek
asked me to run a group
and because people didn't like
what was happening in the chamber,
they asked me to run a group outside.
And then for 20 years,
that became a passion of mine,
to help people find out
what is the right path
for anybody who has a passion
in their business.
How do you do it more effectively,
more profitably, more easily,
so you can spend time with your family
and not spend all your time working,
to me, that's what's important.
I used to tell people
and I don't even know
where this came from,
but I didn't create it,
"You're born and then you die,
and your life is the dash
between those years."
What is the dash stands for?
So, I was born in 1950,
I'm 70 years old.
I have lived an amazing life,
I have accomplished amazing things,
I have 10 books published,
I have my pilot's license,
I used to autocross race cars,
I had downhill ski race won,
first place medals, downhill skiing.
I have conquered all the things
that to me, they were important.
I, today, I can still press
175 pounds with my legs
at 70 years old in November.
I mean, I am such trained
because I never saw obstacles.
I saw a challenge that I could overcome.
So, to me, every challenge has a solution.
And when people acknowledge
that, yes, there's challenges in life,
but that's saying about
it's not how many times you fall down,
it's how many times you get up.
That's been my life.
I have managed to overcome things
that most people can't even imagine.
I had five times in 12 years
medical doctors told me
I would not live six months.
The last time was in 2012
when I went through breast cancer,
kidney failure, liver failure,
all because of a doctors mistake.
I'm here.
I'm here to inspire other people,
I'm here to make sure that people realize
the world they live in
is the world they create.
So, we are not subject
to anyone else's beliefs
unless we choose to be.
So, whatever you want
to conquer in your life, it is possible.
Think about the first person
who ran a four minute mile.
Prior to that, it wasn't possible.
Now, how many people
have run the four minute mile?
So, how many things
could people accomplish
if they only realize,
if somebody else has done it
you can to.
Maybe if nobody's done it, you can.
How many times did it take
for the first space shuttle
to reach the moon?
They had to alter the course
a 1,025 times with the brilliance
of all those scientists at NASA
guiding that spaceship.
So, who are we to argue
with whatever you want to do
you can accomplish.
No matter what it is in the world,
there are no impossibilities.
There's limitations
that we put on ourselves.
And that's what I want the school to be,
is a shining example that these kids
who have been discarded, thrown away,
living on the streets by themselves,
have a chance to live their life
in such a way that they could accomplish
anything they choose.
And people like you,
you're able to go to Stanford,
how fortunate you are.
There's no limit
to what you can accomplish.
You think about Tesla's technology.
They're going to be so many releases
of Tesla's technology.
We're going to see so many things
become available that most of us think
it's just Star Trek technology, right?
No.
Things are real.
Things that we're going to see
coming out in the next few years,
we are going to be amazed
at what's happening.
So, stay in touch, do your own research.
Don't believe
what somebody else tells you.
Don't believe what I say
just because I say it.
But go out
and take that responsibility for yourself.
Don't listen to mainstream media
and think that
hat's the only opinion there is.
You don't read a book and think that
that is the last word,
because you have to make up your mind.
The beauty of living this life
is that we all get to choose
how we live it,
where we live it, what we do.
And you cannot go back at 70 years old
and redo what you did at 25.
So, every year counts.
And I am a living example
of embracing every single challenge
I've ever had and hitting it head on
and realizing that no matter how difficult
the challenge is,
there is a way to get through that
and be able to make a difference
in this world.
And I think
that's what all of us strive for.
Michael, it isn't what we do
behind closed doors,
it's what we do to influence people.
Like a good word, a helping hand.
I try still every single day
to have one thing
as a good work that I do,
whether it's opening the door
for an old man
that would never expect a woman
to open the door,
or helping somebody with their packages,
or it doesn't matter how little it is.
But to inspire somebody
by complimenting them
or making them laugh,
we can make the world a better place,
one person at a time, one day at a time.
And that's what this is all about.
Sharyn, that is just inspiring.
And I am so thankful
for the fact that
you're so generous with your time,
so thank you very very much.
Before we end,
and I'm very very sad that we have to end,
but before we have to end,
I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Innovative, determined, and creative.
Sharyn, thank you very very much.
This was just wonderful.
Stay safe and stay healthy.
And I cannot wait
to share this with the world.
I can't wait to
come visit the school myself
and all the different communities
that you are talking about.
And I can't wait
to continue following your journey.
Wonderful, Michael, thank you so much.
Bye bye.